a teenager at the forefront of the
debate over vaccinations safety is
urging the public to stop the spread of
misinformation about preventive medicine
Ethan Lyndon Berger testified before
Congress yesterday we spoke to the
18-year old last month after he made
headlines for getting immunized against
his mother's wishes our doctor Tara
Narula is here with Holland and Berger
is using his story to educate others
about vaccines Tara good morning good
morning John
Ethan Lyndon Berger says his parents
misguided beliefs in vaccines put his
health at risk he says he doesn't fault
as parents but rather blames the false
information online that manipulated
their fears and is emphasizing the
importance of getting accurate
information about vaccines to the public
to combat preventable disease outbreaks
information is in my mind the forefront
of this matter high school senior Ethan
Lyndon burger joined a panel of health
experts on Capitol Hill Tuesday alerting
lawmakers to the dangers of incorrect
information about immunizations for
certain individuals and organizations
that spread this misinformation they
instill fear into the public for their
own gain selfishly and do so knowing
that their information is incorrect
Lyndon burgers fight against medical
misinformation first began at home about
two years ago after he noticed there was
no scientific evidence supporting his
mother's concerns about vaccinations as
I was growing up and doing my research I
decided that you know vaccines are good
that they are beneficial Lyndon Berger's
mother Jill wheeler worried about
vaccine safety just straight-up
fear of him getting these immunizations
and having a bad reaction Lyndon burger
began getting immunized in December
after he turned 18 he now wants a stop
to the false information swaying others
from getting their own immunizations
it's not necessarily anti vaccine
dividuals but the rhetoric that's being
presented to them Republican Senator
Rand Paul a doctor didn't question
Tuesday's panel but argued against
making vaccines a government requirement
but I still do not favor giving up on
Liberty for a false sense of security
seventeen states allow parents to opt
out of vaccinations for personal reasons
Tuesday night lawmakers in Washington
State advanced a bill that would limit
personal exemptions to vaccines a
measles outbreak in the state has
sickened more than 70 people this year
dr. Arthur Caplan is the founding head
of the division of medical ethics at
NYU's School of Medicine
he says Lyndon burgers testimony is a
major step toward giving children their
own rights to get vaccinated the experts
say vaccines are safe for everybody got
get a vaccination that's good but it's
not as powerful as having an identified
individual step forward and say my
parents are wrong I want to get a
vaccine Lyndon burger says his mom
gained a lot of her anti vaccine
information on Facebook the platform has
repeatedly vowed to reduce false
information parents who have questions
about vaccine safety should visit the
American Academy of Pediatrics website
and healthychildren.org your health care
provider is an excellent resource as
well Sarah why don't you listen to
Senator Paul there he talks about it as
an act of individual liberty but
obviously vaccines aren't just about the
individual gets them or doesn't get them
this is not just about an individual
liberty issue right I'm going to talk
about herd immunity right so there are
individuals who are immunocompromised
and you know their health is at risk
when other children are not vaccinated
but I think Arthur Caplan made a great
point which is is there an inherent
moral right that children have for
health for living a life that is free of
disability and disease and we talk about
the parents rights and the school's
rights but what about the children and
Ethan Linda Berger is really one of the
first to stand up and say children have
rights too and I've another even
speaking out saying she admires her son
for speaking out against her I think I
would say if you have a problem with me
let's discuss it privately
it was Noor it was his mother was wrong
parents were wrong very admirable kid
yes Ethan's doing a real service find it
the Facebook is not medical school
that's right yes definitely there I
think you need that reminder